this is the one thing I love learning
about you so Europe and I feel like this
is like Blake Shelton on the voice he
has like a really wide like playlist a
variety of music that I would never
expect it on a place and some of the
songs that are your favorite songs are
my favorite songs that never would have
guessed you'd have loved them you love
some win Carolus was who's my Jane but
George Michael yeah doing I would just
say that rappers don't usually Jam too
careless which I do in another okay no
they know because if are getting around
certain people not playing they like
what's wrong where did you get the
eclectic taste in music
um I mean how can you hear wake me up
before you go going not one of my father
drove calves in DC during like the one
of the most like trying times in that
area so I would see also obviously
politicians and you'd write along with
yes I'm just riding around DC different
people was getting in politicians
homeless people and I was just
everything and he'd play everything and
he'd buy vinyls and stuff and cassettes
of things because you know he's at this
plenty party had only been in you know
been in the country maybe for less than
ten years so he's influenced by things
he would see out there because he was
born in Nigeria it makes you a great
artist I think that you're well-rounded
cuz it's like seeing your toy list like
I love that that's the taping I was
saying about Blake and like it's so vast
like the music knowledge I think that
that it opens you up instead of just
being like nah don't like that you know
I think well I mean I told what Mark
Ronson my first tour was with Mark
Ronson and I toured the world with him
you know saying and then we took we
opened for jay-z we did art we did
everything so I was literally on that
one that was specific to I was opening
for jay-z with Mark and I was seeing
like justice and Chromeo and all these
things when I never seen them like that
so that kind of solidified much like
what my taste is when it comes to my
career that's really cool man
I love that
yeah it's wrong it's kind of like my um
I guess my the template I guess if you
will for like dating in this this time
is her right now oh yeah so you talk
about tinder
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right now I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this